hello and welcome back to another video
today we're going to talk about tri-gun
badlands rumble which is an action
sci-fi movie with cool characters and
breathtaking action sequences so let's
get right into it the film starts with
the featuring of a hulking thief known
as gasback who's staging a large-scale
bank robbery along with his three
henchmen the employees of the bank end
up becoming their hostages gasback
punishes his subordinate for stealing
items from a hostage as it's against the
ethics of the robbery amongst the
hostages a man talks about how they're
lucky as it's only gas back robbing them
if van the stampede a legendary villain
happened to loot them then they'd be
dead after making eye contact with him
they used powerful explosives to blow up
the traps and big locker of the bank
after loading the money in their cargo
kane a henchman of gas back shoots him
in the face gasback's henchmen turn
against him as they're sick of the
increasing danger and how their boss is
always using the money for the next job
so they're going to kill him and retire
to a life of luxury just when kane's
going to kill him his gun is suddenly
knocked out of his hand gasback quickly
recovers and proceeds to brutally beat
him to a pulp holding the pleading man
at gunpoint gasback plans to pay him
back by killing him for disgracing the
robbery but before he can do this vash
appears from a counter stuns the robbers
with his bizarre behavior and starts
crying over the fact that they ruined
his donuts we come to know that vash was
one of the hostages he struggles with
gasback demanding a replacement donut
allowing the henchmen to escape with
both the money in their lives the police
arrive and surround the building
meanwhile the hostages come to know
their savior is vash also known as
humanoid typhoon gasback wonders why
vash would save even the robbers while
he replies that it's better to be alive
gaspak escapes the police using numerous
explosives as cover an unspecified
amount of time later vash comes across a
newspaper with a piece of news that says
he was the mastermind behind the robbery
much to his dismay twenty years later
gasback's former henchmen are living a
life of ease however their luxury life
turns into a living hell when gasback
returns and takes revenge on one of them
he destroys his casino forcing him to
take refuge elsewhere on the other hand
kane has become the mayor of maca city
under the name kepler he's built a huge
revolving statue of himself with the
robbery money fearful that gas back will
come for him kane insures the statute
for five billion dollars this results in
millie and merrill the insurance agents
coming to the city to prevent the
disaster from happening as their company
would go bankrupt in this case upon
entering the city they meet some rogue
men trying to flirt with them but they
back off after witnessing the huge
machine gun carried by milli they find
the city bursting with bounty hunters
and learn from the marshal that kane has
hired bounty hunters instead of
bodyguards to deal with gasback's
invasion this upsets merrell who
realizes it will be very difficult to
protect the statue in case a battle
breaks out between bounty hunters and
gasbag elsewhere on a sand steamer vash
and numerous other passengers mostly
bounty hunters are traveling to maca
city on the ship two rogue bounty
hunters pick on a pretty girl named
amelia just when the fight's about to
get really dangerous vash steps in and
ridicules the offenders with his silly
tricks amidst his tricks vash saves
amelia and the other passengers as a
punishment the crew members of the ship
throw the offenders out of the ship
along with their luggage they're trying
to apologize but it's all in vain
vash ends up following her because of
his habit of chasing pretty girls
emilia's annoyed by his childlike
advances on her he touches her hand
leading her into further trouble because
she's allergic to foolish men meanwhile
gassback has recruited the skilled
warrior wolfwood as his bodyguard
despite having good intentions he ends
up serving gas back because he once
saved him from dying wolford has a
contract with him and he must escort him
to the house of the mayor of marco city
on the other hand two girls from the
insurance company reached the house of
the mayor upon meeting him they present
him with a gift and suddenly armed
officers cover the place and take the
parcel for checking as it could be a
bomb sent by gasback the mayor tells him
that he needs insurance worth five
billion dollars for his statue because
it's a great asset for the town the
girls tried to negotiate with him but
he's fixated on insuring the statute he
also tells him to insure the power plant
but back off after hearing that it's not
possible to insure a power plant back in
the city vash is still trying to impress
a media she beats him to the ground for
troubling her the two end up in a bar
and share a table with meryl and millie
as the night goes on everyone in the bar
gets high on alcohol this leads to a
huge brawl breaking out just when things
are going to get ugly vash steals the
bullets from everyone's guns to stop the
fight milly and vash head for their
rooms each carrying an intoxicated
amelia and merrell respectively emilia
experiences a flashback in which she is
talking to her mother her mother brings
in a suitcase and says it has a secret
in it which will tell her the future
however her mother falls ill on a
deathbed she tries to tell her about the
case but fails to do so because of a
serious condition as everyone sleeps
gaspak attacks and destroys a factory
owned by gasback's second henchman
forcing him to stay with kane wolford's
magnificent weapon called cross punisher
is revealed in this fight gaspar uses
his electronic arm capable of generating
powerful electric shocks he wipes out
the entire fleet of robots by using
these electric shocks word spreads that
the attack on maca city is only a hoax
and everyone starts to leave emilia is
leaving and vash begins to follow her
but suddenly stomps despite knowing that
gasback will attack this city for sure
he wanted to keep her away from the
danger emilia becomes suspicious of him
and asks him to reveal the truth during
their conversation gasback arrives early
in the morning stating the robbery will
be quite the show the bounty hunters
still hungover from the night before
serve as minor annoyances as gasbag
plows his way through the city upon
reaching kane's doorstep he's briefly
halted by vash wolfwood distracts vash
long enough for gasback to enter the
mansion at this wolfwood states his
contract is complete letting vash inside
gasback discovers that kane has
non-fatally shot the other two henchmen
claiming that they were the ones at
fault death decaying's pleased gas back
is about to get even when vash and
amelia burst into the room vash hopes to
settle things peacefully but emilia
wants gas back dead vash ends up putting
his finger in emilia's gun to stop her
from firing during the conflict kane and
gaspak escape again and emilia learns
vash was the one who let gas back escape
20 years ago she furiously tells him
that countless lives were affected by
his decision of letting gas back live
swearing to see the outlaw die
gasback finds kane telling him that he
doesn't intend to kill him instead he
plans to rob him clean he sets off a
series of explosions that remove the
town's light bulb-like power plant from
its cradle it rolls through town and
destroys the statue to meryl and
millie's great dismay and a special
getaway hover vehicle secures it the
remaining bounty hunters including a
media chase after him vash and wolf
would follow pulling between emilia and
gasback's vehicles trying to stop them
from damaging the plant flash is
suddenly shot by the marshall who's
shown to be working with gas back he
falls and disappears into a pit of dry
quicksand walford tries to save him but
only manages to pull out his sunglasses
grieved over the loss emilia wonders
that she's not too different from the
outlaw back of the now powerless town
immediate tells girls from the insurance
company the vash is dead a media makes
up a mind to destroy the plan of gas
back while claiming back the power plant
of the city because countless people are
suffering wolfwood now wearing flash's
sunglasses agrees to take down gas back
and bring back the plant immediate joins
in the battle they fight bravely but are
quickly overwhelmed by the outlaws
firepower wolfwood provides cover and
tells her to get the powerplant back she
manages to get over the hovercraft by
distracting gas back just when she's
about to escape with the power plant the
marshall comes in and points his gun at
her suddenly just as gasback is about to
kill a media his gun is shot out of his
hand vash appears much to everyone's
great surprise he reveals that he lived
by having the bullet lodge into an
incredibly tough piece of smoked meat in
his pocket he avoids drowning in the
quicksand by having millie and merrill
pull him out much to their shock gasback
challenges him for a one-on-one duel to
which vash and emilia agree vash draws
his gun and shoots him with extreme
precision despite having the power to
kill him he neglects gas back's vital
points indicating that he doesn't want
to kill him the dual ends with gas back
getting shot in the leg and shoulder he
tries to activate his trump card an
energy based weapon but emilia counters
it with a pair of strange metallic
gloves he recognizes the gloves as
something he made for his wife emilia
then reveals that gasback's wife was her
mother and she was born shortly after he
left for a robbery although he left his
family well stocked a rival gang broke
in and stole everything the neighbours
only watched the whole tragedy refusing
to help the family of an outlaw emedia's
mother soon dies as even the doctor
didn't help them emilia then aims her
gun a gas back but then exclaims that
she won't kill him just then kane
arrives with a missile planning on
killing all of them except himself
before he can do this wolfwood destroys
the missile with a single shot from his
cross punisher as the end credits roll
the town's restored once the plant is
brought back vash and wolf would
encounter merrill and mili who state
that kane was a criminal under a false
name so the insurance payment is now
null and void gasback kane the marshal
and the other henchmen are taken into
custody in a police caravan emilia is
watching them from a distance looking on
as her father stares thoughtfully out of
the cell window gaspak experiences a
flashback in which he's leaving for the
robbery and asks his wife to come with
them but his wife refuses to go with the
robber however she accepts the suitcase
given by him hoping to meet him again in
the future vash and wolfwood are then
seen still walking discussing the recent
events wolford brings up the point that
if vash hadn't saved gas back 20 years
ago amelia would never have been born a
newspaper clipping then blows into
vash's face and upon reading it it says
that they're going in a new direction
wolfwood sees that the paper says the
dodongo brothers have escaped from
prison and learns that vash may have
something to do with them so that's it
for today's video if you liked the video
give it a huge thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel for more anime recaps
farewell until the next video